bonjour et une taupe est bourru bonjour
memories au mieux le temps référence des
manuels macro et de son mouvement en
marche en martinique avec vous nous
débutons cycle d'entretiens avec les
représentants et soutient ici en
martinique et des candidats à la
présidentielle française
eric aubin et emmanuel macron qui plus
il a le vent en poupe lui il suscite des
critiques il arrondit tous les angles et
d'accord avec tout le monde me fâcher
personne
il fait le grand écart et au final c'est
lui qui génère le plus d'aidé si sur son
électorat potentiel vous en avez
conscience
écoutez moi parce que je j'ai envie de
vous dire c'est que c'est d'abord un
progressiste et c'est pour lui le plus
large contre le plus étroit donc il est
dans sa position
obligé de rassembler le plus largement
possible et c'est ce qu'il fait et vous
voyez bien que de plus en plus de
personnes considèrent qu'il est le seul
rempart pour protéger la république
c'est de ça qu'il s'agit aujourd'hui
parce que la proposition que ce sera
peut-être une grande expérience qu'on
fera si jamais il arrive à l'elysée
comment faire après une fois qu'on a dit
quasiment oui à tout non vous savez que
d'abord l'élection présidentielle en
france c'est la rencontre entre un homme
et un peuple et je crois que cette
rencontre entre emmanuel macron et et le
peuple français et le peuple d'outre-mer
le peuple d'été des territoires est en
train de se faire alors après vous savez
tout tout tout arriver de nouvelles
sommes à des responsabilités telles que
celle là elle comporte une part
d'expériences oui et il faut l'assumer
c'est un jeune candidat il a 39 ans il
faut en plus il séduit de plus en plus
et il faut assumer où il faut assumer ça
il faut assumer cette expérience et je
pense que aujourd'hui les français sont
prêts à ça et même le demande mais quand
on voit justement que beaucoup d'élus de
parlementaire des ministres et même de
ses adversaires comme manuel valls lors
de la primaire et rallie son vote très
affectueusement on commence à l'appeler
emmanuel
hollande au risque de devenir celui qui
portera finalement toute l'action de du
président sortant durant ces années de
mandature c'est pas une mauvaise chose
pour lui et goûtez moi enfin je pense
qu'il faut assumer une partie de l'île
est obligé d'assumer une partie de wii
de 2,2 de ceux de cette rue qui doit
tendre il est obligé d'en assumer une
partie il en a été le ministre donc bien
évidemment mais mais je crois que avant
tout ce qu'il ce qu'il skie le ce qu'il
essaie de dire c'est c'est qu'il veut
opposer le progrès au conservatisme
qu'il veut opposer l'émancipation à
l'assignation à résidence qu'il veut
opposer la bienveillance à la méfiance
donc il essaie justement de dépasser ces
clivages et c'est ce qui nous amène à
faire ses dents dans cette voie qu'il
nous conduit et je pense que cette
approche est sans doute expérimental
mais peut-être que il va falloir que
nous tentions d'explorer certains
sentiers pour sortir de l'ornière dans
laquelle nous sommes expliqués en
martinique hier éric au fait pourquoi
selon vous votez mâcon serait une bonne
chose l'europe par exemple qui célèbre
ses 60 ans serait selon vous une vraie
opportunité économique la condition de
modifier ou deux petites choses par
exemple le regard sur la mer écoutez moi
je considère que l'europe est une
opportunité et on le voit tous les jours
en martinique
par contre par contre il est évident que
il va falloir que l'europe puisse tenir
compte des spécificités des territoires
et notamment de la martinique de la
guadeloupe de la guyane mais aussi de la
réunion et des autres territoires
il n'y a pas suffisamment de
spécificités fumeux décembre hic est
prise en compte dans l'europe
il me semble que notamment dans
l'agriculture il
on tient compte de plus en plus de ses
spécificités mais je m'aperçois que
malheureusement dans la pêche
on ne tient pas compte de ses
spécificités permettez moi juste un
instant de vous expliquer pourquoi
dans les années 90 il y a eu en europe
une surpêche qui a comptes qui a
contribué en réalité à empêcher des les
deux début des années 2000 la
construction d'un navire
cette surpêche n'a pas eu lieu dans nos
zones y ans ni dans les eaux dans la
zone économique exclusive de la
martinique de la guadeloupe de la guyane
et même de la réunion d'ailleurs est
donc ce qui conduit ce qui nous conduit
et ce qui conduit notamment emmanuel
macron à dire qu'il faut imposer qu'il
faut en tout cas discuter de ses
spécificités
là de manière à ce que nous puissions
recommencer nous à pouvoir obtenir des
financement pour la construction de
navires
si les bains de sang je le sens
extrêmement motivé parce qu'il sait que
la pêche que la transformation
agroalimentaire représente un gisement
d'emplois important ici à la martinique
à la martinique à la guyane est
également en guadeloupe
c'est extrêmement important d'autant que
vous savez et vous le savez ici sommes
ici en martinique notamment nous sommes
pénalisés notre jeunesse est pénalisée
par ce manque d'emplois emmanuel macron
mettra-t-il ça en oeuvre connaît-il
assez nos pays pour avoir envie de faire
bouger les lignes
il a surtout démontré ces derniers temps
méconnaissance de nos pays il a parlé
d'expatriés pour la guadeloupe de la
guyane qui est une île mais il est
évident que nous sommes nous les
référents de martinique de guadeloupe de
de guyane de la réunion
las pour lui apporter cette expérience
moi oui on peut le dire comme quand vous
on peut lui reprocher à lui ça mais on
peut lui on peut reprocher à tous les
français d'ailleurs quand on voit sur
les réseaux sociaux comment certains
français s'acharne sur la guyane
moi je suis je suis je suis je suis
outré penser à certains propos de deux
français à paris ou dans d'autres
régions qui s'acharne sur lui la guyane
donc oui on on peut constater certains
comme on dit un certain ns erreurs de
langage ou domaine des manuels macro
mais qui n'a pas droit à l'erreur et
d'ailleurs ils vous sentez chez lui
vous sentez chez lui une volonté
vraiment de de faire en sorte que nous
soyons mieux pris en considération ce
que ces questions de la sécurité
ces questions de de chômage ces
questions de développement économique de
la situation selon vous que je sens la
volonté chez lui d'écouter
il a une capacité d'écouté
extraordinaire je sens la volonté chez
lui découdre je sais ça
les antillais des chaussures guyanais
jeu sans ces années confédéral ça fait
des années que je sens chez lui
je sens chez lui une volonté de faire
bouger les lignes
je sens chez lui en tout cas sur ces
problèmes de sécurité oui une langage
fermeté et ça il faut l'entendre il aura
le temps de regarder nos pays si
d'arriva à l'elysée parce que c'est une
formule expérimental ce qu'il veut
lancer là est ce qu'il est
il rompt pas en fait de course au final
il y est tellement attaché que vous
savez comme moi qu'il veut basé dans les
autres mers une agence nationale pour la
biodiversité
s'il appuie c'est qu'il a bien
conscience notre notamment de la chance
qu'un mène les outre-mer à la france
ségolène royal a dit carrément la même
chose absolument pas ségolène royal n'a
jamais dit qu'elle allait baser une
agence nationale sur la sur la vie en
avance sur la butte et qu'il faut aller
au delà il faut aller bien au delà il
faut s'en servir comme tremplin il faut
s'en servir comme com
levier de croissance économique il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin est ce que eric
hop est est ce que succèdent emmanuel
macron pourrait bouleverser par exemple
la donne politique locale on rappelle
que vous vous êtes dit suspendu du parti
progressiste martiniquais pour cause de
votre soutien pour pour emmanuel bach ou
est-ce que ça peut changer les lignes
ici moi je pense que d'abord une
victoire d'emmanuel macron changera les
lignes de manière globale en france ça
c'est une évidence parce que je viens de
vous expliquer que les socle de valeurs
sur lesquelles il base sa démarche sont
un changement de paradigme pour la
martinique
je le pense le cakcis aimant jeu
précisément pour le président du parti
progressiste martiniquais serge letchimy
m'écouter d'abord je ne crois pas que
siège de chimie soit candidat à la
présidentielle donc il a soutenu par
contre je si vous faites allusion à ses
contradictions
je veux dire je ne vais pas les
commenter honnêtement je ne souhaite pas
les commenter parce que d'abord ce n'est
pas dans mon agenda
je souhaite me concentrer sur ma mission
de référents d' emmanuel macron ici à la
martinique après les remous du ppm
malheureusement ne sont pas dans mon
agenda
merci eric au fait d'avoir été avec nous
on rappelle que vous êtes référent
d'emmanuel m'apprendre article bonne
journée
[Musique]
dégraisser